. Yesterday I told you that there is desperation
from Donald Trump and from Republicans to
prevent left Parness from testifying at all
in Trump's impeachment trial.
Left.
Parness is a now indicted henchman of Donald
Trump's personal lawyer, Rudy Giuliani.
Rudy Giuliani was involved, of course, among
other things in coordinating the physical
surveillance of ambassador Maria Bonovitch
through love.
Parness.
Remember Rudy admitted he wanted to get Maria
Bonovitch quote out of the way of Trump doing
his bribery corruption in Ukraine.
So we already discussed Republicans are going
crazy to prevent less Parness love Parness.
Now I'm saying it the way a it was misled
said yesterday, Lev Parness Republicans want
to prevent Lev's testimony.
And in fact, hours of debate yesterday during
the impeachment trial was about whether or
not witnesses would be discussed before or
after the majority of the impeachment trial
takes case.
Yesterday I alluded to another panicked concern
from the white house, which is John Bolton,
one of Donald Trump's now numerous former
national security advisors.
Bolton, unlike Michael Flynn, not an indicted
former national security advisor, just one
that was forced out.
It will be very difficult to completely prevent
John Bolton's testimony.
So there were a couple of new strategies that
the white house is trying to sort of, uh,
employ.
One is if Bolton is to testify, negotiating
that Bolton testify behind closed doors.
Mitch McConnell already sort of previewed
this strategy a few days ago.
They might try to do this with some witnesses.
It was alluded to a Bolton is a firsthand
witness to what Donald Trump did.
He supervised the national security council.
He was talking directly to Trump.
Bolton is known for taking extensive notes
of all conversations with people like presidents
of the United States.
They don't want him to testify in public.
So one idea that Trump's legal team had is
to work with Republican senators about when
the discussion finally happens, about witnesses,
which will apparently now happen after each
side has had 24 hours to present their case.
The idea is maybe Republicans can concede
a Bolton testimony, but D, uh, argue or lobby
for it being behind closed doors as a requirement.
And what Republicans are maybe thinking of
doing is if Democrats are going to insist
on Bolton testifying, give it to them, but
force it behind closed doors.
That's sort of potentially trading one nonsense
thing for another, which is we'll, we'll allow
the witness, but we'll force them to testify
behind closed closed doors.
Now importantly, there's no justification
for any of what's going on.
There's no justification for having 40 hours
of arguments before you debate which witnesses
will testify.
There's no justification for pushing John
Bolton behind closed doors.
There's no legal precedent.
There's no historical precedent precedent,
nothing.
Second option, which, uh, was, was, um, uh,
reported on today and again, we, we don't
really know where this is all going to end
up, uh, trading or, or sort of conceding that
Bolton can testify if they agree to subpoena
Joe Biden.
And this is something else we talked about
early on, which is the subpoena of Joe Biden
to Trump's impeachment trial would be a total
distraction.
We are fine or we should be fine on the left
talking about the revolving door of elected
officials, lobbyists, cushy, cushy board positions
and all of that stuff, that's fine.
That is not what Trump's impeachment trials
about.
Trump's impeachment trial is about his wrongdoing.
And that's another idea that is reportedly
being floated by Republicans, which is we'll
give you Bolton if you give us Joe Biden,
which would be a complete and total distraction.
It's almost evil genius and the big story
of course is that all of this is about furthering
the idea that it is the impeachment existing
at all.
That is the problem.
That's what Republicans want to push rather
than the fact that Republicans are participating
in the obstruction of this actually being
carried out in a reasonable way.
They're pushing the idea that it's all too
sensitive to happen publicly.
It has to be done behind closed doors.
I hope that John Bolton just goes public.
Bolton has a book that will be published sometime
this year before the election.
Even if it's just to sell books.
I want Bolton to go public with what he knows.
If he's worried that he might sell more books
by keeping the bombshell revelations only
in the book, I think he'll sell way more books
by becoming the guy who goes public rather
than the guy teasing bombshells.
You've got to buy the book to see.
People will reward him for going public, by
going out and buying the book.
Even if they never read it.
I hope we see him do it.
He's not a good guy, but he may be useful
to us in this particular case.
If he is to simply go public with what he
knows and what he saw.
Let me know what you think about the John
Bolton situation.
I'm on Twitter at D Pacman.
Big show today.
Quick break and back with more right after
this,